bah en fait c'est ça le problème c'est à
dire que les gens ils sont toujours
ambitieux ça fait perdre beaucoup de
poids d'un seul coup alors il commence
très fort en régime ils arrêtent ils
mangent plus ils font du jeûne etc et en
fait au bout de quelques jours il se
sentent pas bien quoi ils se sentent
frustrés alors ils vont craquer ils vont
manger ils se sentent coupable et du
coup ils vont aller jusqu'au bout ils
vont manger encore plus et moi mon
boulot c'est d'essayer de dépister
Benjamin il me dit toujours pourquoi j'y
arrive pas tu as qu'à moins manger ben
non c'est pas ça c'est à dire il y a des
gens ils servent de la nourriture
uniquement pour compenser autre chose tu
es malheureux tu manges tu as envie
d'affectif tu manges tu te sens pas aimé
tu manges en fait il y a plein de gens
qui vont raconter les histoires
tu as pas de souci un petit peu
regardez Gilles pour quelqu'un de
soucieux non est-ce que vous voulez
il y a les deux en fait il y a le
stressé qui a besoin de grignoter parce
que ça compense son stress et il y a le
stressé qui est bloqué complètement et
qui arrive plus du tout à manger mais en
fait ce que ce que je veux expliquer si
tu veux c'est que manger des fois chez
des gens quand on n'arrive pas à se
priver de manger c'est pas parce qu'on
aime la nourriture ou parce qu'on n'a
pas de volonté ou etc simplement parce
que ça permet de d'aller mieux quoi se
sentir mieux alors on va utiliser les
aliments pour se sentir mieux on va
équilibrer ses plaisirs donc faut
arrêter de condamner les gens
c'est-à-dire quand on regarde quelqu'un
qui a un problème de poids on dit ouais
il a pas de volonté il a capable de
manger tu as qu'à manger des légumes et
non il peut pas il est obligé de manger
voilà
on fait comme ça
c'est aussi la nature donc je vois deux
gamins il mange la même chose ils ont le
même âge et tout le mal il y en a un qui
est comme ça et puis l'autre il est
comme ça c'est pour ça que mon boulot
mon boulot c'est d'expliquer tout il y a
les gens c'est hormonal il y a des gens
c'est génétique il y a des gens c'est
accidentel mais il y a aussi des
situations la nourriture elle t'a aidé
dans la vie ça veut dire la Grèce par
exemple c'est un tissu de protection tu
cicatrises avec la graisse t'as pas de
graisse tu peux pas ce cicatriser en
réanimation par exemple chez les brûlés
si les brûlés ils ont pas de graisse
très compliqué de les soigner mais la
Grèce aussi ça le fait de prendre du
poids ça cicatrise des douleurs donc
voilà pourquoi manger ça peut s'attaquer
hyper bien
[Rires]
graisse
t'as pas pris des meilleurs
mais justement c'était pour un peu
calmer tout le monde surtout affida
alors il y a 10 questions à se poser
Jean-Michel Cohen ont réussi son régime
selon Jean-Michel je vais vous donner
les 10 questions qu'il faut que vous
posiez la première c'est à quelle date
avez-vous pris du poids ben oui par
exemple c'est une petite fille qui
arrive et puis on sait pas elle a jamais
eu de problème de poids puis d'un seul
coup elle se met à grossir grossir alors
qu'elle est pas à l'âge de la puberté
elle a dépassé cet âge c'est avant cet
âge et on découvre quand on discute avec
elle que finalement les victimes de
harcèlement elle se fait harceler
harceler à l'école mais elle dit rien
elle peut rien dire parce qu'elle a
honte etc donc elle va manger parce que
elle est à l'écart de tout le monde elle
utilise la nourriture comme plaisir même
chez les enfants il faut que les parents
regardent bien sûr et donc c'est souvent
dans le bureau de d'un médecin comme moi
ou ça va se dénoncer et là d'un seul
coup quand on l'a fait parler on va
régler le problème bah c'est la même
chose la date par exemple à quelqu'un
qui a subi un traumatisme qui a été
renvoyé un boulot elle a très mal vécu
elle peut le dire à personne c'est ce
jour-là qu'elle commence à grossir donc
faut traiter la cause faut pas
simplement lui dire tu vas manger des
crudités de viande etc alors à quelle
date avez-vous pris du poids est-ce que
vous sentez aimé ben ouais ça c'est la
question
en fait ils osent pas le dire j'ai reçu
plein de témoignages et en fait ma mère
ne m'aimait pas et en fait ça existe il
y a des il y a des parents qui aiment
pas leurs enfants ma mère ne m'aimait
pas alors il y a deux choses ça veut
dire elle essaye de se remplir d'un
amour qu'elle a pas ou bien elle va
essayer de masquer sa tristesse comme ça
donc est-ce que vous vous sentez aimé il
y a plein de gens qui ont peut poser la
question tu te sens aimer tu te sens
aimer toi ok bon et donc
[Rires]
est-ce que vous sentez fatigué la
fatigue pour moi c'est un indice de
dépression c'est à dire des gens qui se
sentent fatigués en permanence en fait
c'est des gens c'est vraiment cool
leur dépression ça veut dire ils veulent
pas en ils sont forts ils assument mais
en même temps il y a un fond de
mélancolie et cela ben la nourriture
elle provoque du plaisir la nourriture
c'est un outil du plaisir ça veut dire
ça agit vraiment dans le cerveau pour
offrir du plaisir donc on essaye de
récupérer ce qu'on a perdu mais ça ça se
dit pas d'habitude c'est les choses que
je raconte cette fois-ci mais ça se
disait pas jusqu'à présent faut se poser
la question quel est votre plus gros
complexe par exemple vous ici quel est
votre plus gros complexe fragile on est
mes oreilles non c'est magnifique ça va
hyper bien ensemble
[Rires]
bonsoir
Afida toi tu sais quoi ton plus gros
complexe complète de supériorité
c'est pas mal toi
[Applaudissements]
Béatrice
je suis pas vraiment de complexe mais
attention
je fais pas attention je grossis très
facilement moi j'aimerais savoir parier
par les mieux anglais c'est ton complexe
j'ai pris 15 kilos je viendrai parler
anglais
[Rires]
physiquement j'aimerais avoir plus de
fesses et plus de ça parce que moi qu'on
parle alors bah tu vois
autant en anglais je suis pas sûr autant
là est-ce que parce que toi tu as dit
toi tu es une fille qui mange beaucoup
de protéines beaucoup de hamburger et
tout ça ben moi je suis au contraire je
mange beaucoup de légumes bah oui
justement
[Rires]
purée
mâche potatos pizza
[Applaudissements]
du bon vin rouge du bon camembert de la
bonne charcuterie commence
la question quel est votre plus gros
complexe
oui en fait c'est aussi une question
pour savoir ce qu'il pense les gens de
même et curieusement ce sont des gens
qui viennent pour maigrir donc on
pourrait penser que c'est leur poids qui
est un problème et on découvre d'autres
choses par exemple quelqu'un va dire je
j'arrive pas à parler en public etc donc
j'essaye de dépister d'autres choses le
manque de confiance la peur des autres
donc c'est ça qui met ça ira
non mais c'est régressé vous avez tous
On a tous un complexe
[Rires]
quel bénéfice allez vous retirer de
l'amaigrissement ah quel bénéfice c'est
pas de l'argent Castaldi
français
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de la
maigrissement la première des réponses
normalement c'est maigrir et en fait
c'est pas la première des réponses c'est
se sentir mieux dans ma peau et donc ça
veut dire pourquoi tu te sens mal dans
ta peau explique-moi ça veut dire
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ta vie et
donc une fois qu'on a des c'est comme
une enquête ça veut dire une fois qu'on
a découvert ça on peut arriver à mettre
un nu des sujets et là on peut arriver à
faire maigrir les gens après le reste
c'est la nutrition c'est à dire pas
vraiment ce que tu conseilles à FIDA
autre chose mais
pour les gros culs les gros seins
Darling pas
la question que vous devez vous poser
les 10 questions à se poser pour réussir
sur des régimes si vous nous rejoignez
sur C8 pensez-vous que peu de gens vous
comprennent oui Benjamin oui on comprend
rien dessus donc oui non mais c'est vrai
qu'avant vous voyez c'est vrai
j'ai progressé
le meilleur François
qui comprennent voilà sur le fond oui
j'essaye de m'exprimer mais beaucoup de
gens me reprochent des choses que je
comprends moi c'est l'essentiel
moi tu as raison les gens ne comprennent
pas je te jure quand je suis incompris
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens en souffrance
les gens comprennent pas des fois je
parle je donne des raisonnements mais
non mais tu es à côté de la plaque
parce que tu penses que c'est souvent en
train de dîner avec moi tu es parti
j'étais en train de parler tu es parti
au milieu de la France
beaucoup pour rien beaucoup pendant les
dîners
avec moi il doit pas parler
arrête sympa de manger une autre table
il m'a dit va manger
sinon ça part comme ça tu te retrouves
tu as un morceau de frites qui est pas
toi alors qu'a pris des pâtes
personne ne mange en face de moi la
règle d'or comme ça en diagonale il doit
parler comme ça
il parle comme ça et moi je lui parle
comme ça oui ça va donc les gens
après lui là c'est pas vrai les gens
vont croire arrête
toi tu manges après lui mais
il faut se poser la question si les gens
nous comprennent
ouais non je pose cette question parce
qu'il y a des gens qui sentent dans un
état de solitude voilà il y a personne
pour leur parler en fait il semble
vraiment seul soit parce que c'est
accidentel ça veut dire que vous êtes
seul c'est accidentel il y a plus d'amis
soit parce que vous parlez aux autres
les autres s'en fichent de vous vous
êtes une personne qui les intéresse pas
ben là pareil vous vous réfugiez vous
enfouissez dans le corps et vous avez de
la graisse et c'est seulement quand on a
compris ça que sur certaines personnes
pas génétiques par hormonal pas
accidentelle chez ces personnes on
arrive à pouvoir les faire maigrir en
leur donnant des trucs sympas sans être
peut-être même un burger de temps en
temps ça fait du bien c'est bon plus
tard
[Rires]
du placard ça fait du bien
la bonne bière le coca ça fait du bien
moi j'aime me faire du bien manger des
hamburgers manger des pizzas quand vous
êtes dinde et puis prenez bien
évidemment le livre de notre ami
en fait tu dis que des conneries
[Rires]
non non c'est pas des trucs
ça marche grave êtes-vous satisfait de
votre sexualité c'est ce qui est la
question êtes-vous satisfait de votre
sexualité
on passe à la prochaine
c'est la prochaine j'ai pas envie de
vexer Benjamin
pourquoi pourquoi vous dites ça quel est
le plus gros traumatisme que vous voyez
subi dans votre vie on passe aussi pour
Benjamin
c'est la question qu'il faut se poser
aussi
quand tu poses cette question parfois
beaucoup et en ce moment j'ai un petit
problème c'est que ça rejoint ce que
vous venez de dire je commence à parler
tout seul
est-ce que ça c'est ça et ça je me
demande si c'est pas un signe justement
de traumatisme refoulé de problème
personnel enfin je veux pas faire ma
psychanalyse mais tu l'as fait quand
même
de temps en temps c'est que je comprends
pas pourquoi à un moment donné quelqu'un
a pris du poids alors que elle a 40 ans
où il a 40 ans il s'est rien passé et en
fait tu apprends que cette année-là
justement c'est pour ça que c'est
important la date cette année-là
l'appartement au-dessus de chez elle ça
a pris feu ça lui atterritablement fait
peur elle a cru qu'elle allait mourir ou
un déménagement ou elle a cru qu'elle
allait mourir en fait c'est un méga
traumatisme et donc derrière elle a
mangé pour oublier ce traumatisme
c'est-à-dire pour compenser ce
traumatisme voilà et là après on va en
parler tu vois c'est le psy qui va
régler sa mais moi j'ai trouvé
l'histoire
et toi l'autre dépressif
c'est mon plus gros traumatisme j'ai
couru après en vous donnant aller
chercher des choses maintenant que j'ai
pas eu quand j'étais petit donc du coup
je cours je cours après des choses faire
des choses tu te raccroches à la vie non
non c'est vrai alors
c'est des conneries ce que je suis en
train de faire ça se trouve je suis pas
dans le bon chemin je cours après
quelque chose on va faire deux trois
[Rires]
je t'ai pas parlé à toi
insupportable c'est insupportable quoi
j'ai fait du bien franchement
hier soir encore il a mangé avec moi
mange tous les soirs avec moi
on fait du bien à Jean-Marie il y a
beaucoup de monde exactement
dès que je viens vous voir je me sens
mieux quand je repars je me sens mal
ouais mais c'est pas une raison pour
rester tout le temps avec moi
non c'est vrai
non mais toi je te fais du bien fila
aussi
depuis des années chérie c'est vrai
c'est pas moi si je te gonfle pas j'aime
bien
non mais
l'Amérique moi j'adore
tout le monde vous êtes très sensible
sous vos aspects comme ça
quand je te masse les pecs j'adore ça
[Rires]
y a-t-il une situation qui revient
souvent dans vos rêves Gilles toi il y a
une situation qui revient souvent à
l'intérieur il y en a plein de
situations qui reviennent la pire
laquelle c'est quand le sol en ce moment
qui s'ouvre sur moi je suis terrible et
je m'accroche à des choses ou des gens
qui disparaissent mais oui mais oui
[Rires]
mais tu as peur de la mort si vous posez
des questions les bonnes questions dans
le livre la peur de la mort de la mort
excuse-moi il a tiré il y a deux
secondes la carte
de la mort les mecs à mon avis voilà
lundi il fait le vainqueur 45
lundi c'est une spéciale avec des images
de Gilles Verdez derrière voilà c'est
vrai je la connais je vais arriver comme
ça
c'est un signe ça
et c'est quand c'est difficile que ce
rêve là revient ah ouais c'est
exactement votre question où ça qui fait
des rêves comme ça
et puis que tu rames de plus en plus
c'est quelqu'un qui court après lui sans
effort il te rattrape et ben ça veut
dire que tu as envie d'être rattrapé en
fait ah ouais
c'est vachement intéressant c'est pas
ton impuissance c'est qu'en fait tu as
envie quand tu rattrape alors que c'est
un cauchemar Raymond toi voilà parce que
c'est important tu es quand même moi
souvent je rêve d'un truc je suis en
voiture à la montagne je fais marche
arrière et en fait il fait nuit et je
tombe dans un ravin avec la voiture
alors ça ça me fait quand même un grand
merci comme un grand vite là
je suis dans l'eau je je ressors de
l'eau et je suis au milieu du Parc des
Princes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le mec qui avait envie de faire
une carrière dans le
foot et après je tire la chasse d'eau et
comme je dise
[Applaudissements]
quand on fait des rêves qui reviennent
souvent comme ça ça veut dire quoi pour
le c'est une préoccupation qu'on a dans
son cerveau et en général on l'a on l'a
transforme on voit pas l'événement
direct on va transformer ça et en fait
il faut qu'on l'interprète pour savoir à
quoi on pense réellement parce que lui
il adore les voitures il aurait rêvé
d'être joueur de foot
et les poissons donc il va dans l'eau
c'est tout bah oui c'est tout regarde
moi je rêve souvent
que je suis en finale de Roland-Garros
exactement et je me réveille le matin je
suis chez moi comme un con ouais mais ça
fait du bien
je rêve de ça mais c'est toujours pas
rencontré
[Applaudissements]
pour la société
disons il faut que ça démarre vite mais
la semaine prochaine il sera là
la semaine prochaine
mon fils va péter ton père tout va bien
se passer
t'inquiète pas c'est quelqu'un de très
sympa
alors tiens aussi la dernière question
c'est ce qu'il y a des reproches que
vous n'arrivez pas à faire à des gens
autour de vous
[Rires]
deux non à vous à vous non et je vais le
faire à l'inverse quand ça va mal on se
sent seul et grâce à vous et vos équipes
qui sont là en permanence toujours
autour de moi c'est là on se sent mieux
donc voilà c'est plutôt l'inverse c'est
vraiment la solidarité docteur qui fait
qu'on s'en sort est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça il faut pas rester dans
la réalité
j'ai confiance en lui il a un aspect
patelin bonhomme sympathique elle fait
que quand il parle je vous crois
heureusement qu'il y a des gens autour
de nous docteur merci merci non bien sûr
il y a des gens par exemple quand tu es
chez toi tu supportes pas quelqu'un et
tu peux pas lui dire par exemple tu as
je parle pour ces gens qui ont besoin de
la nourriture pour qui ont besoin de la
nourriture pour compenser quelque chose
tu supportes pas ton patron par exemple
moi
tu refoules tout ce que tu as envie de
lui mettre dans la gueule en toi et tu
vas manger et ça va servir à ça voilà
non mais ça va je suis pas ton patron
ici
je te repose la question si vous
n'arrivez pas à faire à des gens autour
de vous moi j'arrive pas à faire des
reproches à mon meilleur ami parce qu'on
a grandi ensemble on a le même parcours
et lui il a une carrière il est
directeur de centre de formation il a il
a il a une maison qu'il a déjà payé il a
tout tout est bien il a il a une belle
voiture électrique tout est bien
j'arrive pas à lui faire des reproches
il fait mes déclarations d'impôts il
sait tout faire il faut faire une
cloison il fait une cloison il faut
faire de la plomberie c'est de la
plomberie tu me vois pas non mais je me
vois pas les lui dire là par contre tu
as merdé sur ce truc là je me dis fais
tellement de trucs bien qu'est-ce que tu
vas aller me chercher à lui dire la
vérité mais j'ai du mal à faire des
reproches même avec vous par contre vous
c'est pareil je vais pas vous dire que
je vais faire comme reproche
il y a des gens comme ça ou tu dis
qu'est-ce que tu as fait toi par rapport
à lui pour lui donner des leçons et à
des gens où tu dis bah tu peux dire la
vérité tu peux dire la vérité au mec
mais le reproche c'est un truc encore
c'est une mec va très bien mais quand
c'est un parent par exemple ou ta mère
et qu'en fait par exemple je connaissais
une fille elle était célibataire elle
était obligée de s'occuper de ses
parents elle arrivait pas à leur dire ça
me pèse en fait vous voyez ce mot ça me
pèse
la dernière fois je vous jure que c'est
vrai et je te le dis Jean-Michel non
c'est vrai c'est un truc qui m'a marqué
j'étais chez ma mère et j'ai pas osé lui
dire que les boulettes étaient trop
salées
pas trop gras les boulettes il y a juste
un filet d'huile j'ouvrais la le
couvercle de la marmite les boulettes
c'était comme des navires sur l'eau
et je disais bon ben non il y en a pas
beaucoup mais en fait il y en avait
trois litres quoi Delphine c'est vrai
que boulettes
j'ai jamais eu de soucis de poids j'ai
toujours été très très fine mais par
exemple pendant mon année Miss France
j'étais pas très bien dans ma peau parce
qu'effectivement c'était compliqué
vis-à-vis des gens vis-à-vis même de
l'organisation Miss France et j'ai pris
5 kilos je n'ai jamais été aussi épaisse
que quand j'étais Miss France
effectivement tous les soirs après je
mangeais je mangeais mais à me faire mal
au ventre
avec les autres la Grèce et c'est pour
ça que les mises
pendant l'année généralement elles sont
elles prennent du poil c'est un peu plus
difficile à gérer tu viens de comprendre
ça ça veut dire que je viens de
comprendre là maintenant
[Rires]
Jean-Michel c'est toujours un bonheur
Jean-Michel Cohen mais maigrir pourquoi
j'arrive pas ça c'est nouveau ça qu'on
se pose des questions vous avez vu hein
ça fait beaucoup de bien exactement
n'hésite pas aller le voir en
consultation